boa tarde a todos
é um prazer estar aqui podendo
compartilhar um pouco do meu universo
que vocês
quando a gente é pequena as pessoas
sempre me perguntam o que a gente quer
ser quando crescer e que as crianças
atualmente respondem bombeiro astronauta
jogador de futebol eu desde pequeno era
fascinado por ciências e sempre me
perguntavam o que eu queria ser quando
crescer eu respondi a cientista maluco
eu cresci continua apaixonado por
ciência da engenharia porque gostava
muito de matemática e física mas lá
pelas tantas acabei entrando no mundo
dos negócios com esses objetos tão e
quando me formei e me tornei consultor
em gestão e mais tarde empreendedor
hoje eu tô aqui pra falar um pouco de
seus conhecimentos que eu tive nessa
trajetória empreendedora pra vocês
para começar eu queria saber se alguém
já pensou em empreender com tecnologia
principalmente mais alta que a metade do
pessoal
quando a gente está começando a aprender
eu acho que uma das primeiras
dificuldades que a gente tem é como
tirar o nosso papel
normalmente não têm dinheiro para
contratar um bom programador e achar um
bom jogador tem o perfil complementar o
nosso terça disposto a entrar nessa
empreitada é muito difícil nessas horas
a gente sempre pensa se ao menos eu
fosse jogador a gente começa a achar que
o conhecimento mais importante para
criar um negócio é o técnico que
descobriu que não é bem assim
o conhecimento mais importante para
criar um negócio sucesso a entender
sobre comportamento humano
hoje eu falar um pouco das teorias por
trás dos produtos que a gente usa
diariamente mudar a minha forma de
enxergar um antes quer dizer que é muito
importante que a gente usa essas teorias
para que a produtos serviços que a gente
acredita que fazer bem com as pessoas
alguém sabe dizer por que as empresas
novamente falhou novamente falhou que
constroem algo que ninguém quer
ou seja ela não falhou porque tem uma
dificuldade técnica de construir sua
visão mas eles não encontram ninguém
dispostos a pagar por essa bola seja
pensar nas teorias mais tradicionais e
novos negócios
ela fala para a gente criar um megaplano
de negócios
olhando todo o mercado dos concorrentes
depois de desenhar um mega projeto todas
as funcionalidades que o produto deve
ter os recursos necessários o programa
de desenvolvimento passar meses ou anos
envolvendo esse projeto planejar um
megalançamento para solar no final e se
as pessoas gostaram de diferença
se a gente pensar que quando a gente
está criando um negócio a gente tem
muito pouco dinheiro consequentemente
pouco tempo essa estratégia suicida e eu
sei isso aconteceu comigo passei dois
anos envolvendo um produto que ninguém
quis
foram milhares de linhas de código
fechado conta que quando está inovando a
gente está pisando no terreno totalmente
desconhecido ea primeira coisa que tem
que fazer é descobrir quem é o nosso
cliente ele quer e se uniu e mostrou
muito bem esse objetivo
a gente normalmente começa querendo
adquirir o usuário fazendo com que ele
use cru
depois de que ele entenda a proposta de
valor gosto do produto realmente volte a
utilizá lo
por fim a gente quer ver se alguém
disposto a pagar por aquilo esse funil
vai ganhar toda a apresentação
daqui pra frente então falar de teorias
por trás de cada uma dessas etapas
como falei o primeiro ponto é adquirir
usuários
quando falei que o usuário está falando
em construir algo tem valor pra ele e aí
que entra a chamada lista tanto ela
basicamente devido à construção no
produto e pequenos círculos interativos
de desenvolvimento interação com os
usuários e aprendizado
ou seja em vez de passar anos gastar
muito dinheiro tempo construir um
negócio que a gente não sabe se as
pessoas querem a gente tenta validar
nossa porta com relação ao negócio mais
rápido possível colher no feedback ao
longo do caminho pré ajustando à nossa
trajetória
o objetivo é aprender a gente errar cada
vez menos um ponto muito muito
importante essa teoria é o mp ou seja o
menor produto viaduto com o qual a gente
consiga validar a principal hipótese
um negócio meu caso era que as pessoas
querem ver playlists classificadas por
tipos de atividade de gênero
quanto menos a gente conseguir
desenvolver de código para testar isso
melhor
o importante é que a gente consiga
simular uma situação real
uma pesquisa por exemplo é uma forma de
fazer isso
na pesquisa as pessoas sempre falam que
comprariam tudo o que gosta de tudo mas
na hora tirar a carteira do bolso é bem
diferente
um caso muito legal e vamos fazer isso é
de software de sincronização de arquivos
entre plataformas
os caras fizeram basicamente um vídeo
mostrando os arquivos e cruzeiro entre
as plataformas botar um botão de
download clique aqui para ter o produto
quando era aplicável é encaminhado para
uma outra página que falava à produção e
desenvolvimento de seu nome seu e mail
quantia pronto a gente vai mandar pra
você porque ele não tinha desenvolvido
uma linha de código mas com isso eles
conseguiram validar que milhares de
pessoas queriam aplicar essa mentalidade
pode ser usada para praticamente tudo
a gente pode inclusive criar anúncios
pra ver qual o melhor título de um livro
basta a gente media a taxa de cliques
por visualização de cada anúncio para
ver qual era a atividade
depois que eu saí criar um produto
entender o que as pessoas querem criar
um grupo que elas gostem do nosso
objetivo passa a ser aquelas pop aos
produtos para reter seus usuários
quando a gente fala de atenção a gente
está falando de criação de hábitos de
uma coisa que aprendi ao longo desse
caminho é que os produtos podem ser
desenhados para criar os produtos que a
gente usa diariamente podem ser
classificadas em dois tipos as vitaminas
são aqueles produtos que melhoram nosso
dia mas que não são essenciais e os
analgésicos são aqueles produtos sem os
quais a gente não consegue ver a maioria
dos aplicativos que utilizam diariamente
percorreram muito bem esse caminho de
começar com vitaminas se tornar um
projeto
as redes sociais por exemplo ela
normalmente começa com uma brincadeira
mas quando a gente vê que está viciado
nela tenho certeza que muita gente aqui
a primeira coisa que faz de manhã é
pegar o telefone para a rede social
esse agente privado a pessoa disso isso
vai causar um grande desconforto
o ponto é que a gente sempre acha que a
perda com a formação muito importante
pode estar circulando por ali a criação
de hábitos é basicamente
interessado no gatilho externo que pode
uma publicidade e recomendando aquele
produto
nunca tive interno é uma emoção um
sentimento que faz lembrar que a hora de
usar aquele produto é como se o produto
sem coração uma sensação nossa o momento
do dia a dia um cara chamado e ao
desenho foi muito legal quando se faz
isso começa claro com gatilho que nos
leva o produto nos passar informação ali
dentro ea partir dessa ação a gente
recebe uma recompensa em determinado
momento a gente é recomendado fazer o
investimento pode ser em tempo esforço e
dinheiro
esses dois últimos quadrantes não tem
mais espaço para a gente falar em termos
de teoria ponto muito legal da
recompensa é a variabilidade dela em um
experimento com bombos um grupo de como
foi colocado que apertar o botão e
sempre que apertasse o botão receber
comida
já o segundo grupo apertar o botão e só
de vez em quando receber comida porque
eles virão aqui a freqüência de
apertadas do hotel o segundo grupo era
muito maior que o primeiro
ou seja o fato da gente não saber se a
recompensa vai realmente acontecer faz
com que a gente passa a relação de forma
muito muito mais compulsiva
agora pensa a gente está rolando nossas
redes sociais
é como se a gente fosse pouco procurando
por comida a gente passa um tempo ali
achando que aquela próxima informação
mas aquela informação na nossa vida mas
normalmente é um gatinho bonitinho
o ponto é que a gente é viciado e
mistério
o investimento também muito legal porque
é pra mim essa etapa é totalmente contra
intuitiva
eu sempre achei que quanto mais simples
for um produto mas ele chegou a utilizar
é totalmente o contrário quanto mais
investimento a gente faz o produto mais
valores passada pra ele mas a gente
volte a usar o experimento muito legal
de pessoas foram convidadas a construir
origamis e depois verificar se obrigando
todos os casos o preço dado pelo
construtor foi superior ao projetado
para o terceiro
eu acho que é por isso que os pais
sabiam seus filhos e aqueles mais lindo
de todos
o interessante é que o preço dado por um
construtor para o origami de um outro
construtor também é superior ao preço
dado para o terceiro ou seja começa a
reconhecer o esforço dos outros também
o que a gente conseguiu constatar que a
gente conhece
eles possuem um computador no nosso
grupo de empresas tem um aplicativo que
basicamente se conecta à zona sul e vai
pela cidade
você gente baixa o aplicativo ele fica
rodando em background vai se conectando
zonas vai falar que ele conhece a senha
era pura mágica
o ponto é que as pessoas não viu ele
trabalhando e não dava valor nenhum pra
eles que a intenção era muito baixo o
que foi feito
eles transformaram aplicativo totalmente
manual ou seja depois de baixar o
aplicativo te apertar o botão de baixar
as senhas na prática seja estava tudo
ali pasha animação ela 20 segundos
baixando assim mas depois na hora de
achar as redes de carregar todas elas em
50 milissegundos podia ser feito ela
apareceu uma uma como o segundo
intervalo entre cada um e assim como
isso várias funcionalidades em real
valor foram feitas e com isso a gente
conseguiu triplicar a retenção do
produto
depois de algumas pessoas querem
conseguir fazer elas usar e voluntários
ao produto surge um objetivo talvez seja
o mais difícil de qualquer estado que
conseguir concretizar aquele produto
seja fazer as pessoas pagarem por aqui
lá e quando a gente fala de fazer o que
pagar por uma coisa é importante criar
valor e por isso ele está no tapetão
fundamental mas o que eu descobri é que
o valor não é uma medida tão absoluto
assim tem exemplo muito interessante uma
revista onde tem dois planos de
assinatura
o plano a é 60 dólares e as obras são
digital
o plano b é 125 dólares na versão
digital mas sem pressa e vocês aqui
compraria a ver seu a levanta a mão quem
vocês e vocês compraram meia então a
maioria que respondeu 99% compreender o
ser humano de fato 84% das pessoas assim
na versão a agora é só acontece quando
se espera uma terceira opção ser essa
opção basicamente não faz sentido algum
de fato ninguém assinou a versão ser mas
o simples fato de não existir fez com
que a versão b passa a ser muito mais
bonita ea proporção das assinaturas do
totalmente
é impressionante como uma variável que o
valor zero tem poder de vetar
o valor e assim como isso a sensação de
que a cesa uma coisa que afeta a nossa
percepção e fazendo de pagar mais mais
rápido por algo ou então aquelas ofertas
do mercado são tão boas que ela limita o
número de unidades por cliente
quando tem esse limite de idades a média
de unidades compradas por pessoas maior
é quando não tem limite de idade nem
hoje eu vejo que a web é um laboratório
permite que a espécie de coisas em alta
escala e com muita velocidade e que
inovar é saber gerenciar uma sucessão de
experimentos tirando o máximo de
aprendizado de cada um e construir um
produto ou serviço melhor e se hoje eu
sou o fato o senhor empresário de certo
modo a vez que eu falei aquilo que eu
sempre queria com a criança
hoje eu sou um cientista maluco obrigado